good afternoon welcome well some of you
hadn't been in our earlier session so i
will introduce myself I am ernesto
zedillo director of the Year Center for
the Study of globalization and the
students that just show up I want to
tell you that we are having a conference
which we have title nuclear weapons the
greatest peril to civilization we have
had a very interesting program this
morning looking at the historical the
intellectual history of the ideas of
nuclear abolition we have looked at the
consequence of the use of nuclear
weapons ambitions in scenarios and we
have had a very interesting speech by
the High Commissioner on disarmament
ambassador sergey Duarte and I think now
we are getting to the very in spirit
inspirational moment of this conference
you know it's always good to have a
inspiration in life and we received that
inspiration for from many sources but
particularly from exceptional
individuals and today we have with us an
exceptional individual a person who
really has done many things in life and
by doing that he has inspired others to
perhaps not to imitate him but to pursue
from their own perspective goals that
are similar ideas that are similar to
those that our participant at this
moment has pursued in life and that
person is a Ted Turner many of you know
him as a very successful businessman I
like to define Ted Turner as one person
that well before
the Microsoft guys the Google guys the
internet guides really was one of the
Modern architects of globalization
because what he did with tienen a couple
of decades ago was precisely that give
the world a degree of interconnectedness
a degree of access to information real
time that we hadn't seen before in human
history and this was with television and
this was by placing people all over the
world to report to the world what was
going on in the most distant places in
the world and Ted Turner I insist before
internet goddess globalize but even more
interesting is that Ted Turner rather
early he also started to have big
concerns it worries about the big
problems that are shared by humanity at
large he started with great talent to
point to situations which mean or ring
about a threat to humanity that cannot
be addressed by a single country alone
problems that need international
cooperation to be to be addressed I
think one of his greatest achievements
is to do something that some times
people like to put in rather burn acular
teams you know terms put your morning
where your mouth is and death has used
he success as a businessman to support
those causes which it is very important
for countries for people for diplomats
for leaders to speak and come to two
fundamental agreements one field in
which he particularly has distinguished
self is on the question of
non-proliferation and disarmament
nuclear non-proliferation and
disarmament right after the end of the
Cold War Ted noticed that there was a
unique historical opportunity to retake
or take with the specific actions this
enormous challenge of proliferation and
disarmament and he promoted this
initiative which is called the nuclear
threat initiative which has been a
fantastic mechanism to secure Danglars
nuclear materials and also to support
the disarmament effort particularly of
the Russia and not the former Soviet
Union and he put money into that
enterprise and he attracted great
political leaders to be part of that
cause so I cannot really think of a
better personality to come to this
conference and to give us some
inspiration and that is why I am so
happy and so proud to welcome you mr.
Ted Turner thank you
Thank You mr. president for that glowing
introduction I really really appreciate
it and I want to have 20 minutes saw for
my presentation and then I think we have
30 minutes or so for discussion and
questions and answers I want to start by
making the statement I have given a
great deal of thought over a number of
years to the nuclear situation and all
been very concerned about da band and
and worried and and and thankful at the
same time that that nothing has
seriously gone wrong that we have it had
a nuclear a nuclear exchange or nuclear
annihilation but but but but my
conclusion and I'll talk about how I got
there a little later my conclusion
because I want to be certain to make it
very clear my conclusion is that the
only solution to proliferation the only
way that we're going to get out of this
box that we have built for ourselves is
a complete abolition of all nuclear
weapons all over the world and agreement
by all countries not to make use deploy
or do anything wrong with with with Bob
with any weapons of mass destruction but
certainly not not nuclear and I just
feel feel like that's the only way we
got all the countries of the world have
to play by the same set of rules we
Jonathan shell has a wonderful new book
book out seven decades and I just just
finished reading it and he comes to the
exact of exact same exact same
conclusion the smaller countries in the
world they have the same rights as the
larger countries and for us to sit there
with 10,000 nuclear weapons and tell
everybody else in the world that they
can't have
particularly when we go allow Israel to
keep their hundred nuclear weapons and
and also we were opposed to Pakistan and
India at the time but just as soon as
they got them well they join the club
after you if you don't get blown off the
face of the earth by the United States
in the first year after you get new
nuclear weapons then you'll be you're in
the club you know and once you're in
it's okay but that's [ __ ] you can't
you can't ask people to do that by god
we've all got the same rights and
another thing the United States need to
do is quit telling everybody what in the
world what they need to do and if we
want people to be like us and I guess
there's nothing wrong with that oh the
way to do it the way to get them to be
like us is to do such a good job and be
so prosperous and happy and set of such
a good example that people will want to
mimic it that's sob that's the way to
get people to come along with you is do
like Tom Sawyer did or Huckleberry Finn
you know make it look like so much fun
to paint the fence that everybody else
grabs a brush and paints the fish first
they don't want to go fishing they'd
rather paint the fence so i really love
i really feel that that's that's the
only the only way and and also we have a
we have an opportunity now because we've
got several challenges that really are
that really odd where the world of our
humanity faces are terrible dangers and
right behind the nuclear threat right
behind it is the global warming threat
and the concurrent collapse of the
environment that's occurring all over
the world we've got to walk straight in
that situation out too and then the
third thing that we've got to get
control over and another book i strongly
recommend to you is Lester Brown's
latest book plan B 3 point 0 which deals
with all the world's problems at two
hundred and some odd pages and uh and
then it's got all the solutions
in there too and and the third the third
big problem that we need to work on is
stabilizing population because as Lester
says in his book if we don't stabilize
population all the other things that
we're doing are going to we're still
going to go down the drain because they
just we just cannot keep increasing
exponentially the way the way that we
have then because we just put too much
at the tax on on the natural environment
and it can't can't support more of us at
a decent standard of standard of living
those are the three major challenge
humanity faces and we really need to
tackle them all right now and we need to
have successful conclusion so why not
put them all together i mean there's
going to be a lot of it's not going to
be easy to have total nuclear
disarmament and certainly not to have it
in a reasonable period of time and i
want to make one other one other point
dog is that in thinking how we're going
to get there how we're going to do it
that there has to be some sort of some
sort of rough plan that work where it
can show that the countries of the world
that it can be done and I trying to
think of a solution to that how we
actually go from the nuclear weapons
that we have now with eight or nine
nuclear powers to zero as quickly as we
can why not a five or a ten year plan
where we freeze we agree at the United
Nations all the countries of the world
due to to freeze them and and and
gradually reduce them over a five or ten
year period ten percent say ten percent
a year that the United States with
10,000 nuclear weapons would would
destroy a thousand a year of Pakistan
with a hundred nuclear weapons would
destroy 10 a year so we'd all stay for
those 10 years relatively the same and
da bit because we're going to have to
have a plan that treats everybody
relatively equally and when we get to
the global warming situation it's
another another set of problems
they're not going to be able to do that
equally because the developing countries
don't pollute the atmosphere anything
like God at the rate that the that the
wealthy developed nations are that use
much more energy so that we're going to
have to come up with a special formula
for that it's going to be the most
difficult challenge that humanity's ever
faced but we have to have 191 countries
agree on that on a nuclear situation we
only have to have eight or nine
depending on whether North Korea really
has nuclear weapons or not I don't even
I don't know it doesn't matter but kind
of encounter mallet at dog at some point
that's the other thing we're going to
have to have is complete inspections all
over the world what countries are all
going to have to agree to that but that
doesn't that shouldn't bother as week it
we can do that we have the IAEA and we
have the United Nations we already have
oh we already have the bodies that we
need to administrate this they're
already in existence they don't have to
be invented and for the most part they
have most of the world's respect and
admiration and because they've done so
much so much good are they perfect no of
course they're not perfect but nothing
that we do is perfect but we're going to
have to get closer to it now than we
ever have before or we're going to be
toast and dog and and and and and our
planet is going to be toast to I mean
not to think the thing that really
upsets me one of the things that upsets
me is that with with nuclear
annihilation and it'll happen sooner or
later if we don't get rid of the weapons
saw the weapons are going to get rid of
us I mean it at some point because just
remember a couple of months ago that
b-52 bomber took off from Nebraska and
flew down to one of the Gulf Coast
states was Louisiana Texas and they had
four armed hydrogen bombs on the plane
that got on accidentally 6 i'm sorry
that's right Matt had six and they
didn't even though they were on there
and for several days they
were missing they did when they landed
they didn't know they had them on there
I mean jeez let me just get that we
should all say it when I as we say our
prayers at night say thank you God for
getting us through one more day that you
know one more day of life of where we
haven't blown ourselves up I mean what
kind of sense does it make to destroy
millions of people children and think of
those of you how many people like their
museums you know I mean I like museums
but you know we're going to blow up all
the museums I mean you know there'll be
nothing left if anybody did arrive here
a million years from now after we after
we burned the world update they wouldn't
be able to find hardly any record that
we were here you know I mean at least
the Pharaohs I mean Egypt i was just in
Egypt beautiful and I went around and
saw all the out antiquities and went to
all the museums I'm kind of a week doing
it at least there's still a record but
but by god if you take you take a couple
of hydrogen bombs and and explode them
right over the pier visit Giza there
wouldn't be two stones left on top of
one another you wouldn't be able to find
all find a thing in ND yah the curator
of your museum was at our dinner last
night he's probably here right now that
runs the museum here and you know it
would be a real shame to use lose Yale
and the music museum you know it's so
anyway that this could be the what we're
going to exterminate all the higher
forms of life with that with nuclear war
there won't be anything left except
maybe a few cockroaches that's a hell of
a thing to have done to ourselves you
know it's it's one thing if we get
struck by a meteor we have a bunch of
volcanic explosions that that that grown
up the world but to actually commit
global suicide I mean is life that bad I
I just got back this summer I went to
the Galapagos Islands I took my family
they looked at all the tame animals that
you can they won't let you pet them but
you could because they sit right there
because people don't kill them and beat
them up down there and I came back I
came back saying this world is worth
saving this world is worth saving life
is worth carrying on so let's not
deliberately kill ourselves who wants to
commit global suicide and who wants to
kill millions of people children
grandmothers grandfathers who wants to
do that nobody I talk all over the world
I never find anybody wants to do it then
why in the hell that we have these
weapons sitting there why do we I know
why we built them during the Cold War
but the cold war's over we're in another
era war is not the way to get things
done anyway the great military powers of
today are not going to be the powers of
tomorrow that the countries that are
going to be the great powers of tomorrow
the ones with the best educational
systems the ones with the belt
healthcare the ones with the best
science and technology the ones are the
best businessman the ones with the most
integrity those are going to be the
countries that are going to be the
champions of tomorrow and then look at
this stupid military stuff in a war look
at the war in Iraq here we are with a
500 billion dollar military budget and
we're being defeated or at least tied by
a group of guys down there the Taliban
and and they don't even have generals
and they don't have a headquarters and
they don't have any tanks they don't
have nothing but a few rifles but but
they're able to buy by being guerrillas
and having moved into the cities they
negated the tremendous strength that the
United States had and it's not just us
we're not the first superpower we
already lost in Vietnam we killed three
million people in Vietnam we lost sixty
thousand i think it's 150 or 1500 you
know if you count the body count we want
but you don't do it that way is who's in
possession of the country at the end of
the day and the Vietnamese were in
possession of their own country for the
first time in a long time thank goodness
every time I see a Vietnamese anybody
from Vietnam
on the road what whenever I see one I
apologize for what we did to their
country they didn't attack us they pose
no threat to us whatsoever we just
decided we're going to do a preemptive
war just like we've done in Iraq and
we're not the only ones the only
superpower that's been defeated by the
developing world country the Russians
were beaten in Afghanistan too we're
getting beaten there to incidentally we
have so few people there that they're
growing their opium and we're not
stopping that you know it's a drug
situation anyway I think that's about
can I can we go to question answer I'm
about out of time anyway anyway that's
my presentation now we'll have a little
question answer thank you very much well
I promise you that this would be
inspirational it has been because Ted as
usual as a lever and tether has accepted
to take a few questions whoever wants to
make a question should walk mic
microphone let me say one other thing
mr. president I just want to make it
very clear which I didn't say earlier
because I didn't have a prepared text I
wanted to speak from the heart rather
than just read something and I want to
make it clear that the opinions that I
expressed our mind not necessarily that
of the nuclear threat initiative which
I'm on the on on the board of or the
United Nations Foundation obviously
support the United Nations I'm wearing a
tile I'm a strong internationalist aw
but I just want to make clear that those
were my own personal opinions we should
more people and more institutions share
your opinions make the first question
thanks for coming today I have two
children adopted from Vietnam so I
appreciate your remarks about the
Vietnam Vietnamese I am hard of hearing
too that's another thing so I'm gonna
probably yeah they did and please yes
okay yeah that's good that's right okay
my name is Linda gan truong with beyond
nuclear and I have two children adopted
from Vietnam so I wanted to thank you
for your remarks about Vietnam and and
it's such a it's a country that forgives
so well when I visited there the world
can we get is incredible I wanted to ask
you about the five hundred billion that
we've already wasted in Iraq and what
how and when you think about what we
could do with that money and how we
could apply to good in the world have
you any advice or thoughts on ending
this hemorrhaging and being able to
start to use that money wisely well
first of all I I neglected to mention
that Lester Brown and I think it's
around a hundred billion dollars here to
straighten out all the world's problems
that have a have a school lunch program
for all the poor kids in the world so
they get at least one decent meal a day
the poorest kids in the world license a
of and to educate everything sure
everyone has an education do we do away
with illiteracy and and and the other
the other problems that Jeffrey Sachs
and the Millennium Goals the United
Nations to eliminate poverty over over
the next stop over the next few years
will take about a hundred billion
dollars a year and and and the global
military budget is one is is 10 is 10
times that much it saw a trillion
dollars a year and the u.s. is half of
it we're spending now close to 20 times
as much as Russia and 20 times as much
as China which is the other two largest
countries in the world and they are not
our enemies we we have a very very
strong military industrial complex in
this country frightening Lee strong so
strong that they basically are spending
money and every congressional district
in the United States saw and and and
they like making money and selling all
this crap this useful
stuff aircraft carriers I mean what
good's it you know we put them in the
Gulf there bye-bye Iran and we run them
up and down you know yeah good deal you
know what you know we could attack if we
want it but you know I'll tell you I
don't think we should you know I think
that's really really foolish but but we
should cut our military budget way back
over a period of time I think because
we're wasting that money and we're we've
got these huge deficits now because of
the war in Iraq and because of this big
bloated military expenditure and dog if
we're going to if we we're going to have
to cut back on our military budget are
unconventional stuff if we're going to
get the Russians to agree with us to go
without nuclear weapons then they have
to feel like we're not threatening right
now we threaten we threaten the whole
world and because of our military but
why do we need such a huge military
budget who our enemies we don't have any
enemies other than poverty and terrorism
there's no nation is it an enemy of ours
the Chinese just want to sell us keep
selling as shoes you know they want to
get cars they want to have a good life i
mean the Chinese aren't our enemies and
neither are the Russians if we and
something else we need to go back and do
we should have done i said at 15 years
ago the Cold War ended is we ought to
have invite Russia to join NATO that
then you don't even need NATO but why
not then invite them in I mean they not
our enemies but treat them like friends
that's what I did the goodwill games and
this is the middle of the cold one we
got along great you know it's next thing
you know the cold war was over it was it
very hard what do is bang
thank you I'm my name is Jeff Alexander
I'm a sociologist here at Yale and you
pointed out how your rationale this
nuclear arms race is so it would seem to
be a matter of just common sense but I'm
the sociologist so I want to ask you
what would be the social conditions that
would have to convince these governments
in other words i remember back the
nuclear freeze movement which was a kind
of a social movement don't you think we
need that kind of mobilization of the
base of people around especially in the
u.s. at least and elsewhere it has to
become not just from the elites down but
from the bottom up well guess what we've
got Bob we've got a candidate running
for president Obama has already come out
publicly and said he's 40 nuclear
weapons so we haven't had a presidential
candidate that I can ever remember say
that not a serious one and and and and
we've got job you know you've got
secretary George Shultz and Sam Nunn and
Henry Kissinger and bill Perry the four
of them have done those two editorials
of affairs in the in the in the Wall
Street Journal and they've gotten a
whole lot other former big cheese's in
our government that want to get rid of
all nuclear weapons we're closer today
than we then we've ever been it's not
going to be easy but it could be because
you know it's just time that we stop
doing dumb things and start doing smart
things you know i mean really i mean
it's that clear and everybody can
understand that everybody can understand
it in Africa and Asia and Europe you
know because we've got this global
warming thing and everybody recognizes
that too and while we're working on it
we might as well straighten everything
out there like an alcoholic that decided
to give up the booze and straighten his
life that you know thank you um how
likely is it that if the United States
were to declare our intentions to fully
disarm or buy whatever gradual plan how
likely is it that the rest of the
nuclear countries would follow suit and
does that matter well what we have to do
first of all Britain has already
announced it their new secretary or
whatever has already said we want to get
rid of nuclear weapons completely as
soon as possible so you've got one of
the eight that's already agreed now
we're not going to i do not advocate
that week that we unilaterally declare
we're going to get rid of our nuclear
weapons what we should declare is that
we're ready to sit down and discuss
getting rid of them if everybody
everybody's got to get rid of them at
the same time and agree night not to do
it and the countries that don't have
math to have to agree to that too but
just remember this there are eight
nuclear countries now maybe not there
have been four that have already
disarmed Ukraine Belarus kakaka Stein
and South Africa have already given up
their nuclear weapons those three former
republics of Soviet Union send them all
back to Moscow you know you can have
them we don't want the goddamn things
pretty smart huh anyway anyway y'all but
we'll do it together and and and the
pressure on everybody first of all
people it's the right thing to do and at
the end of the day if we're going to
survive particularly with a high
technologies that we have like nuclear
weapons we're going to have to learn to
be a little bit smarter than we were in
the past we just can't go around hitting
each other over the head with swords and
knives and stab each other and you know
first of all that's uncivilized and
inhuman you know what we want to do is
start acting like decent kind-hearted
intelligent educated human beings that's
you know what you do that you don't want
nuclear weapons hi I'm Mary Ellen I'm a
freshman here I'm in the nuclear
dilemmas class um you mentioned a couple
of objectives being one being
eliminating nuclear proliferation
another one being dealing with
overpopulation
now as a lot of Nations said they want
nuclear energy in order to deal with the
rising needs these to deal with
overpopulation all them by themselves
turning to that energy source but that
energy source is one that as mr. she'll
explain to our class is about seven
tenths of the way to making nuclear
weapons what's your opinion on nuclear
energy and is it really well I can
answer that I like solar and wind better
because they're cleaner and there'll
Essex less expensive Bob and they'd and
nuclear power is still dangerous because
we still haven't figured out what to do
with it with the waist however I believe
it knowing that countries that want to
build nuclear power plants it's fine I I
don't think you could have nuclear power
with low enriched uranium which is not
weapons grade so I don't think we should
and obviously a countries that have
nuclear raw cycles and capability
anybody can build a nuclear weapon if
they want to but if we've all agreed not
to do it and we have supervision with
the IAEA who's going to cheat what are
they going to do you know I've got one
or two nuclear weapons so you've got one
or two nuclear weapons you know but
there's there's a way of dealing with
that too if you have one or two
countries in the world that absolutely
refuse to cooperate that a truly rogue
states whenever if everybody else
decides they want to get rid of nuclear
weapons but one or two countries there's
a way to handle it and peacefully and
that is you boycott the country's the
whole world the United Nations you give
them warning say if you don't go along
with the rest of us we're just going to
boycott you which that means is you have
nobody come into your country you can't
airplanes can't land anywhere else we
won't trade with you do whatever you
want to inside your own country but no
country can handle out in the age of
globalization no country can stand alone
like that and it wouldn't be worth it so
they could have two nuclear weapons you
know so what we're going to do with them
you know that's the other thing what are
we going to do with our 10,000 are we
going to dump up on Russia if we do the
radio
active cloud comes back within the next
few days and we're dead to its using
nuclear weapons on a large scale is
suicide so they're no good for anything
except to threaten your neighbors we
don't like you and we could bomb you if
we wanted to you know so you better do
what we say but they don't do what we
say Saddam Hussein didn't do what we
said the Vietnamese didn't do what we
said and if during the Vietnam War if
during the Vietnam War we would have
given ho chi minh and ultimatum say
listen we're sick of this war it's gone
on long enough and we want you to
unconditionally surrender by next friday
at noon or we're going to hit you with a
hundred nuclear bombs you know what he
say bring them on he would have then
what we do go do it haha it's it it's
unthinkable who's got the next question
Rebecca Johnson acronyms Institute for
disarming diplomacy in in London I love
the way you think and talk about these
issues and I have a mission for you
which is to get yourself into a room for
a one-to-one with Gordon Brown without
any of his business as usual advisors
there the reason why I say that is
you're quite right the mood music in
Britain has changed and there's all this
lovely talk about how they have a vision
of a world free of nuclear weapon how
they want Britain to be seen as a
laboratory for disarmament note this is
vision and seen this is all about
management of news because the decision
three months earlier in mayor s are in
March of last year was forced through by
Tony Blair to get the next generation of
British nuclear weapons to take us not
just beyond 2020 which the current
system beyond the 2050s why three
reasons were advanced in only three one
was this status you've dealt with that
the big powers of the future are going
to be those that have well educated
healthy intelligent forward-looking
populations not the ones with big
weapons you got that the second one is
insurance policy that we don't know what
the future might hold will will guess
what we do know quite a lot of what the
future might hold and if we don't deal
with climate change and if we carry on
putting a lot of resources into
the weapons will end up with nuclear
winter and or climate change my question
is the third and that's the job creation
scheme libitum the industrial aspect the
defense industries push on governments
to keep going with the military and keep
going with the nuclear weapons you as a
brilliant entrepreneur and industrialist
how would you convince Gordon Brown to
ignore that pressure and indeed convince
the leaders of the other nuclear weapon
States so that we actually can move
beyond the rhetoric into the actuality
of getting rid of nuclear weapons what
was the question in a nutshell come on
over other you can be in zip gordon
brown brow yeah 30 billion pounds that
they are planning to spend in the new
trident okay system right right right
got it got it thank you guy first of all
as i as i already said the way you've
got to start this is not because the
united states spends money to and
rushing to spend money we all spend
money on our weapons we have to sit down
and agree to get rid of them and an end
to end and to freeze work if we're going
to get rid of them if we agreed to do
that then there's no point in
modernizing them you can save that money
and everybody would do it if they but
you've got to get all the nuclear powers
plus the rest of the world to agree to
it now the rest of the world's already
agreed to it as already agreed to it in
the nuclear non-proliferation treaty
which the United States and Russia and
all of the nuclear powers except India
Israel and Pakistan those are the only
three countries that didn't sign but
France did so and they agreed that
they've agreed to get rid of nuclear
weapons already back in 1956 we just
haven't done it so all we have to do is
to rob is to live up to the live up to
what we what we signed and this is it
it's very short I keep it in my wallet
at all times july first 1968
eat this is quote each of the parties to
the treaty undertakes to pursue
negotiations in good faith on effective
measures relating to the cessation of
the nuclear arms race at an early date
and to nuclear disarmament and on a
treaty of general and complete
disarmament under strict and effective
international control we've already
signed the treaty only I have to do is
sit down and agree that we're going to
get that we're going to live up to what
we've already agreed to thank you um it
seems to me the problem is that if we
were to abolish nuclear weapons there is
nevertheless still a dramatic imbalance
in terms of the military potential and
strength for example the United States
certainly relative to the rest of the
world so how do we tie conventional
military strength into the nuclear bomb
I don't think I think that that the
nuclear situation is so critical that we
need to deal with that deal with that
first of and as part of it the United
States is going to be under a lot of
pressure when we get to the global
warming part of things to cooperate
there and that's going to cost us some
money too and I think that will lead to
a cutback in our military budget over
over time it won't be easy because of
the strength and power of the
military-industrial complex but it's not
good for the berrykin people and that's
crazy I mean what are we going to do
like the whole world at once what we're
going to fight them for I mean if we
don't that the invasion of the United
States is taking place along the Mexican
border right now but it's not it's not
coming with tanks or landing craft
they're walking across the Rio Grande
they find a job you know that's all you
know it is all this military two
aircraft carriers aren't any good for
that the first of all the Rio Grande is
all dried up because of the drought and
you couldn't float that aircraft carrier
in the Rio Grande it it's it's not even
but a creek I know but
I it runs right by my house in New
Mexico so the nuclear weapons don't make
us any safer i mean we're getting beat
in Iraq right now with our nuclear
weapons what are we going to do drop
drop nuclear weapons on Baghdad what
about all the guys that we've got there
and we've got a lot of friends there too
you know all right I'm Alan robock from
Rutgers I'm trying to think who is the
current situation good for its good as
you mentioned for the big companies that
make all of this stuff and global
warming situation is good for Exxon that
cells cells oil mix 40 billion dollars
how can you how can we practically
attack them they're the enemy because
they want this now they know we're the
enemy in my opinion it's a sigh I wish
job I wish it was if we could blame it
on ExxonMobil that they just make the
gas they don't run it around in their
cars and there's a lot of ways to
mitigate that for instance I've got it
for the last six years I've had a Toyota
Prius a hybrid when it just came out and
I doubled my gas mileage job there's a
lot of things you can do you don't have
to and I even in my office now I keep
the one the blinds up and I turn the
lights out and I sit there in the dark
in my office working you know because I
don't want to turn on the lights but but
but that's okay i'm trying my very dead
level best to to do the right thing and
if everybody does that will be able to
handle this we're going to be able to
handle this solve the global warming
thing too but it's going to take a lot
of effort but it'll be it'll be fun i
mean you know never before in this
through the world have human beings done
the right thing on a consistent basis
this will be the first time you know
that'll be fun to be there I want to
live long enough to see it happen that's
why i want i'm going to be 70 this fall
and i don't know how many years I've got
left and I want to live long enough to
see global nuclear disarmament god damn
it that's what I want and I'm asking the
rusty all to help me that's that's what
I want for my 80th birthday
I want to be able to lay down my
deathbed and say my grandchildren and
all the other grandchildren were safe
for the foreseeable future wouldn't it
be nice huh how many y'all have
grandchildren you know how many love
them how many don't give a damn where
they get blown to kingdom come or not no
come on and that's true of the Russians
too right you bet and the Chinese are we
not done yet now I'm dick Garvin if i
look back to the reagan administration i
see that the Bureau of the budget wanted
to tax all the money put it into defense
so that we wouldn't be spending it on
social goals we have that problem we
cannot make up our mind we have earmarks
go to individual districts but we have
very great difficulty deciding how to
spend the money that we can raise from
the population what do you think we can
do about that if we do reduce the
defense budget you know just do the
smart thing no I yeah you got that
that's that's all stuff that you work at
with politics you know not the nuclear
disarmament will be worked at eventually
the politicians will be involved with it
with it too but but you know in a
country at a free country of where we
have elections we can change the
government so we ought to put into
government that that's going to do what
we want them to do I mean that I voted
they'll you know during Bush's first
term and I voted for al gore and if we'd
have gotten him as president we would
already have global warming would be of
a receding problem instead of a bigger
one we made wrong choices but we got to
start making the right choices that's
all if we do that we'll be fine you know
if we're smart we're fine if we're
stupid we lose I take the left thank you
I'm an caliber is he a member of this
community
mr Turner you are the master of
communication on what you are the master
of communication you have got it down
cold and I imagine that there are a lot
of people that would agree with you do
you see a way that our new magical
internet and your way of communication
can get this message out to a wider
audience that convinced all over the
place it's already there Lester Brown
how do we connect them where's the guy
that's here that wrote seventh
generation he's going to speak this
afternoon he's got the answers just to
do what do what do what those two books
say and you'll be fine connect them how
do we connect them I don't know Rita
both won back-to-back it's all the
information is out there I mean it's all
over the internet it's all over the
place you know if I can dig it up you
can't you already told you Jonathan
shells book his latest book just came
out read it and oh I i I'm doing my
autobiography is going to be out after
the elections over please buy it too
there's a lot of good information in
there and anyway Lester Brown's book
plan B three-point Oh read those that
you've got it made that's all the
information you need takes a couple
hours you're done